ah la la qualité des pêches
bonsoir
d'euros michel delpech de pouvoir vous
rendre 720p dommage mais quand on écoute
tout ça on se rend compte à quel point
vous avez été important dans la chanson
française est vraiment quand on entend
ça on peut qu'être admiratif des
formidables outils de façon un peu
étrange d'accueillir l'invité mais je
crois que pour vous c'est la meilleure
en tous les cas c'est sympa vraiment
merci bien alors vous êtes là parce que
vous sortez à vous ressortez d'abord un
best-of avec tous ces titres et puis un
nouvel album donc ils s'appellent cadeau
de noël qui est là voilà
galloway
qui est sorti donc le single s'appelle
cadeaux de noël et le cd s'appelle cas
d'audrey et c'est un bon cadeau de noël
voilà donc tout ressort en ce moment on
est heureux de vous voir en forme avec
avec la pêche
vous connaissez nos amis bah ouais j'ai
fait connaissance voilà mallory n'a donc
qu'à des ogives et quand la raison de
lui voilà linda hardy frédéric
mitterrand vous dit en parlant de se
disent que c'est mon disque le plus
accompli depuis les années 70 oui moi je
trouve pas forcément ici enfin c'est mon
avis personnel c'est vrai c'est un des
meilleurs lycées sorti depuis longtemps
8 que ça ressemble c'est le plus
ressemblant la musique à ce que j'aime
et ce que j'écoute comme musique chez
moi et c'est vrai et je vous souhaite
qui marche aussi bien que les morceaux
conçus que ce que j'écoute voilà c'est
marrant parce que rien ne prédestinait
être chanteur au départ un mode père
était artisan dans la galvanoplastie
donc au départ c'est pas vraiment
quelque chose qui vous prédestinait à
devenir chanteur 1 et la maison surtout
qu'on écoute et tino rossi
j mariano chez dell pèse donc voila mais
vous dans votre coin vous écoutiez
brassens bécaud aznavour quelques
chansons d'aznavour vous ont le plus
marqué tu te laisses aller il faut
savoir si magnifique tout beaucoup de
chance aux ados amour j'aime toujours
autant bien sûr mais c'est vrai que ça a
été pour moi
déclencheur quoi alors un jour je sais
pas comment c'est arrivé vous êtes au
lycée de pontoise fêtes de fin d'année
il ya l'histoire c'est quoi il ya un
directeur artistique dans la salle qui
s'en aperçoit plus en version qui
souhait un des pions du lycée qui
maillent qui était d ailleurs champion
de france de saut en longueur par la
même occasion vrai et il s'appelait
lemahieu et il avait ville avait décidé
de me propulser un petit peu afin de me
faire connaître des gens lui connaissait
pas grand monde non plus mais il s'est
battu pour qu'on rencontre directeur
artistique maison de disques naïve
olsson bah oui je sais nous avons bonne
série mais qu'a lancé dutronc déjà des
disques vogue et disent que c'est lui
qui a lancé antoine enfin d'abord les
problèmes
françoise hardy et enfin se passe ils
nous regardent mais je commence
maintenant
je venais fille ordinaire
il faut que je me mets shima bon enfant
tous les cas jacques bolson est un mec
bien
alors là vous faites trois morceaux qui
n'ont pas été que sont pas impérissable
anatole on fait semblant j'aime la vie
ce cas mieux marché s'est beaucoup pesé
film comédie musicale à cette époque
l'apsap les plus attrayants base est
même resté six mois la niche se
débrouiller j'étais pas mal vous a
permis de rencontrer votre première
épouse chantal simon et alors là vous
écrivez chez laurette alors ce qui est
extraordinaire avec cette chanson
si vous l'avez écrit d'une traite dans
le train de paris à saint cloud et oui
c'est la seule d'ailleurs que j'écris
aussi croire en ses murs j'étais bien
mort ce qu'on peut dire sans être
désagréable avec vous c'est vrai que
c'est une période alors quand même au
début de votre carrière très très
agressive
mallory nous disait tout à l'heure moi
j'aurais tuer père et mère pour être
célèbre s'élèvent pour faire ce mythe
pour faire ce métier oui pardon pour
faire ça mais c'était quelque chose de
magique moi j'avais posté une muninn
atteignable et on fait faire un casting
quatre jours après celle sur un plateau
par des drogues et michel c'est vrai
michel décla cd malheureusement enfin
malheureusement pas malheureusement
parce que vous avez passé plus avec tout
ça c'est des vous avez dit j'avais soif
d'être connu d'avoir ma photo dans sl
c'est vrai il est on vous a vu la
semaine dernière
c'est jean marie périer qui étaient là
et alors quand vous étiez en vedette
américaine nous disiez géant tournée je
fais tout pour avoir autant de succès
que la vedette
c'était vraiment oui elle avait vraiment
là bas j'avais envie de l'envié d'y
arriver et manifester un peu sinon
j'avais envie de tout fracasser j'avais
besoin qu'on parle de moi
tassé de schiste en france c'était ma
seule motivation je connaissais rien à
la musique et la chanson ma seule
motivation c'était que ça fonctionne
explique j'ai des savanes petit chanteur
mais c'est sympa parce qu'elle est
définie on gagne là-bas c'était facile
j'ai fait des trucs incroyables squeeze
je demande et vous attaché de presse de
mettre le paquet je montrais même des
choses de ma vie privée vous avez fait
une photo nue avec bojan entendre ici
par et au support très brillante non
mais bon ça va
description non non on pouvait s'en
passer il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
vraiment causé beaucoup posé nue vous
auriez dû vous moi j'ai posé aussi j'ai
vu dans la grosse émission avec juste un
petit cache sexe de bull racing pour
louer 2 dans l'émission de je sais plus
qui c'était moi j'ai posé dans caravane
magazine et comme glace hier -1 venus
toujours un jour ils viennent même temps
moi je comprends ce que des michel on a
un peu le même parcours
on a commencé tous les deux trois mois
j'étais dans le train touristique entre
leurs essais cette cdm en lui leur être
mais là il était michel delpech qu'on
voit là très calme très sera atteint la
maturité ce qui me gêne c'est quand
j'entre dans un lieu public et de pas
être certain qu'on me reconnaisse et
quand il ya des gens qui me demandait ce
qui m'énerve c'est quand les gens me
demandent des autographes aux yankees en
disant qu' est-ce parce que quand même
c'est wes et c'est nouveau ça c'est
vraiment une époque
non mais j'ai pas encore une fois c'est
un chiffon 75 cv ou premier problème
d'abord avec votre fameuse première
épouse chantal simon qui la défense un
peu vous avez pris un peu de temps c'est
pas bien c'est pas bien j'avais acheté
mersen
ces poulets arsène wenger sortie de
notre ville
est ce que c'est parce que vous aviez
peur de pu rester en haut vous avez
commencé à vous défoncer un peu ou pas
ce que votre femme annonce non non non
non non seulement c'est ça bien à vous
je vous disais à l'époque si je deviens
second dira que je baisse donc avec ce
désir d'être quand on est en haut le la
peur que ça s'arrête quoi ces voix là il
est en train de décrire à personne sinon
j'ai pris conscience si michel à cette
époque un peu du côté dérisoire donc
d'être un chanteur de charme une idole
d'aider des minettes nom du vissoir nous
en fait c'est pas vraiment dérisoire de
tensions autour de chambres sur donne 10
ne trouviez pas ça dérisoire si à
l'époque je suis à l'époque était dur
avec les chanteurs français
il a fallu attendre la fin des années 70
pour ont commencé à admettre
michel berger des gens comme ça parce
que avant ça c'était fallait qu'ils sont
anglo saxons les chanteurs oui moi j'ai
été très marqué par le par le succès de
pour un flirt en fait mais qui m'attaque
à naviguer pendant très longtemps comme
chanteur tube 1 ça a été un peu pénible
à vivre pour moi parce que j'étais bon
j'avais envie de montrer autre chose que
je savais faire
mais voilà et alors après donc vous avez
connu un trou noir vont sur lequel on va
passer tente beaucoup mais la grosse
vague hausse des prix morlaàs et plus de
la rigolade
c'est la grosse déprime cure de sommeil
quelle heure on se raccroche à ce qu'on
peut les voyant les marabouts les
gourous il ya même un sacré il ya même
un psychiatre pour qu'on doit dire de la
rançon cas plutôt un boucher qui nous a
proposé qu zi la seule solution dans
votre cas c'est la lobotomie
c'est dur quand même
tu imagines on en a parlé j'étais seule
espèce d'eau stockées et j'étais seule
il y avait personne pour me conseiller
donc lui le dire vraiment réfléchissez
bien
il m'a laissé un soir angie gens qui
réfléchissent et on se revoit demain je
vous assure que néanmoins que vous
sentiez bien désormais c'est de faire
une daube automation maintenant alors
j'étais à deux doigts de lui dire oui
parce que à cette époque j'étais
vraiment dans une situation et il ya une
petite tentation quand même
finalement il ya eu un vieux gros centre
du loir-et-cher qui étaient là et tu
termines métier bas ça serait sympa de
me recevoir aujourd'hui avec une
lobotomie c'est parce qu'on a fustigé la
malchance et et alors là lors ce qui se
passe est extraordinaire dans ses dix
ans mais j'adore les destins 6 passes
dans cette histoire c'est que il dit bon
je me cassais je pars aux états unis
vous avez vendu vos droits sur le nombre
de chansons voilà le type ce bar quoi il
est au moment de partir vous rencontrer
geneviève garnier fabre qui est une de
vos le voisinage ou artiste peintre et
là miracle tout recommencer que choisir
la vie quand même ces vivaces qu'elle le
dire et là c'est la résurrection miracle
vous venez croyant en fait un voyage à
jérusalem qui vous marquent beaucoup oui
vous dites je me suis éloigné du brasier
et voilà hélas pour commencer à remonter
ça nous a pris quand même temps pour
vraiment vous en sortir je peux pas je
peux pas dire exactement parce que
c'était une longue route vrai le
longueuillois ending l'aude
mais est-ce que c'était du la question
qui est ce que c'était dû uniquement à
la s'était pas dû qu'à la défense votre
état j'étais du tout un tas de choses
n'ont jamais petit jamais dire qu'il ya
une chose c'est un ensemble de vingt
deux choses s'étaient pas lié à des
choses professionnels non hein c'était
vraiment un mal être je suppose c'était
quelque chose qui était en moi une
faille qui étaient là que j'avais pas
remarqué
alors on va terminer là dessus vous dit
ce qu'on va voir un petit document à
sens et je préfère ma tronche
d'aujourd'hui à celle que j'avais avant
je me soumettrai vue
avec mes chemises à fleurs et mia ou
flac end magnéto serge en aura besoin
m
tu
soit
c'est commun
tu sois et
vim
je vois
du soin
m
à
secteur
cela pourrait être besoin d'eux
et nous
puis
g
us
oui
pêche wight is wight alors quelle
pension effectivement il disait j'ai été
très con quand j'étais jeune banon des
considérations c'est vrai en fait tous
avril
on est on est jeune plus on passe à
d'autres mais même chose on n'est pas
plus cons là que là et quand tout le
temps